our crews had their hands full overnight
battling blazes all across the valley on
the fourth of July
now some houses were impacted by those
fires leaving people without a place to
stay tonight or co-manage oins us live
from one of those homes near Jones in
the 95 with the latest details on this
or Co WA Sasha this is one of the
busiest fourth of July's for Las Vegas
Fire and Rescue one of the reasons for
that is some buildings were damaged this
is one of the homes fire crews responded
to last night we're told these palm
trees caught fire and the blaze extended
to a parked vehicle here and also
charred part of the house at least five
homes were damaged across Las Vegas and
some people who are even displaced this
was video sent to us from a viewer it
shows a string of fireworks lighting off
a fire inside the garage of a Centennial
Hills home some fireworks shooting into
the sky and smoke filling the street
there were also around 175 calls last
night and this morning the most Las
Vegas fire crews have ever received
during the 4th of July a majority of
them were outside tree fires or fires
that started on the roof we're told
that's a pretty good indicator they were
caused by fireworks but most of the
cases are still under investigation
luckily no major injuries have been
reported but officials are still
disappointed did not look like that they
were taking safety in to procore safety
precautions in some cases that there was
nearby vehicles and there was sparks
hitting them and that so actually I
think we got off better than we could
have just looking at in the pictures but
there were a lot of fires out there that
could have been even potentially more
dangerous
fire departments across the valley also
stayed busy last night this is video of
a house fire in Henderson near galleria
and mccormick it burned for nearly three
hours neighbors tell us people in the
area were setting off fireworks as a
reminder the only fireworks people
should have been using are the safe and
sane fireworks those are the ones that
do not shoot into the sky but since the
holiday is now over those are not
allowed as well reporting live in Las
Vegas tonight Orko mana 8 news now